hello um first up i just wanted to say
this show i was in tears by the end i
don't want to like obviously give
anything away but
like so lovely and it made me think
about like my childhood and like the
toys i had growing up did you guys have
any toys that you just like could not
let go of when you were kids
mine was monk monk was a stuffed monk a
stuffed monkey so
kind of the most original name ever
yeah i had him i had him always slept
with him took him everywhere and my mom
still has him and occasionally my nieces
aren't super into monk maybe because
he's like 35 years old
but he's still cute and he's still
he's still around and he still gets
tactile child time
gina
i didn't really have anything i was like
particularly
um
specifically fond with i had lots of
stuffed animals
but my older sisters were i mean they
used me like i was there
teddy bear but you know i would snuggle
with them and they would like play dress
up with me and make me their doll and
i enjoyed that i enjoyed that a lot
i feel like i'm an older sister and i
would put my little brother in like
dresses and suits yeah but i was like
you you are like the life-size doll here
um jonathan i love your voice in this um
it's so good i mean obviously you know
we know that you've done voice over work
before with frozen but like is there
something in particular you love about
doing this type of work
i feel like um
i feel so connected to childhood stuff
maybe maybe because i'm an actor i
really remember like i remember my
friend andy playing in his backyard and
i remember i even remember moments like
being called to go inside
and hours went by and it was like i had
transcended
uh and i think that's
i think that's why i'm an actor is
because
i am trying to i'm always chasing
that feeling that i had as a kid playing
pretend
and so getting to voice
and a toy
uh a beloved toy and we're playing
pirates and all that stuff
i felt really um
i felt really connected to that and and
like
like getting the chance to
play with kessler as even just as the
voice um
was an opportunity to reconnect with my
own
child-like imagination and self
i love that um gina uh congratulations
to you um on your pregnancy i know this
was done beforehand but do you sort of
view this role differently and are you
excited to one day show this project to
your child
right
i'm back i'm back it's just because my
dog likes to participate in all of these
interviews um i
you know when we were shooting this i
was already starting to have
conversations with my partner about
being parents and
you know um and anytime i have a chance
to work with a young actor
i always want to protect them so badly
because it's such an
interesting experience and um
you know i think at that age to be
working is so strange
and you should be playing and you should
be outside running and you should be you
know using your imagination hopefully
not like in a work environment but this
lost ali allowed kessler to to play in
his full imagination and so this was
very special and the environment that
peter ramsey created for kessler and all
the other boys that played his younger
self was one that was full play
full play
and
um there was no rigidity to it that made
it feel like work because i've worked
with you know young actors before and
you just want to make sure that that
environment feels like home
and that it feels safe
and so all the while i just
and because he was also playing an
adopted child
you know i just and we want to adopt one
day i i just was um
it was just very uh emotional for me it
was very connected to
i guess what i'm going through right now
but
what i desired what i longed for i
longed to be able to have a child to
play with and to play imagination like
you know just to be fully
in the space of magic and never take
that away from them so i'm hoping i
don't do that to my child i don't want
to take their imagination away from them
um but now i look back on on lost dolly
and the time that spent that we were
shooting in and i was like
oh that's why it was so special because
i wanted it so bad
you know
[Music]
that's so sweet well thank you guys so
much for taking the time really
appreciate it you guys have a good one
thank you
you